[Music]
hi I'm Keeley
um and this is foliage Parts in St Louis
Rams game first and foremost to a plant
shop that's what we are house plants
indoor house plants and alongside that
we do the coffee and the cake as a
well-being gesture towards that you may
be into plants you may not be but you
still get that kind of calm chill bottom
at the shop you come relax with friends
or on your own you can do work from here
and it's kind of best to both really
loads of different plants plants that I
like plays that you know that I think
are really easy to care for try not to
have plants are too much hard work but
we also have other things so yes we do
the teas and the coffees but we also
sell the range different plant pots I
make my own soil so
um I have my own little mix that I bag
up and I sell on the shelves house clock
mix Cactus mix easy peasy and but people
love it because it's in small bags I
haven't had all the mess at home they
also do like little repotting kind of
Spades and little trays to make having
house plants easy really
also got people that just come in for
their teas and coffees they have their
usuals they're walking Kayla my usual
please so I get to know couples and
families that come in regularly and then
we have people that discover us new
house upon people so they come in and
like what if you've got news if I've got
a new delivery coming in they're kind of
picking up on social media and they come
and have a look what's new and so yeah
it's a real mix with people people live
locally some people travel down you know
all the way from whitstable and someone
came up and chatting yesterday because
they found this online and just
somewhere different to go to and yeah
it's a kind of a real mix and getting to
know people that live around here is
quite cool the Vic has been in this
morning yeah good
this year is making sure we've got
everything that people may possibly need
and so we've had two massive orders of
plant pots coming in so people got
different pots to order for gifts and
lots of candles coming I'm making little
gift baskets there's lots of gift
baskets in the shop that people can just
purchase they can pick their plants put
them in I am slightly out of Ramsgate so
people want to come and rub and go on
locally they have to come out and find
me but just by somebody coming in having
a coffee once a week or buying the house
plants from us rather than huge
supermarkets or DIY stores would keep us
going
oh
[Music]